the President of the United States
dedicates the National Institute of
Health in Bethesda Maryland six hours
ago the presidential special train
rolled into Washington's Union Station
bringing the president back from his
one-day New England tour which ended in
Boston last night and now the president
has come by automobile to the National
Health Institute in Bethesda Maryland on
the outskirts of Washington we're on a
pleasant Indian summer afternoon a
moderate-sized audience has gathered
before the White columned redbrick
Institute administration building set in
the green rolling Maryland hills and
surrounded by trees thick with red and
yellow autumn leaves
mr. coy
dr. Thompson the governor of Maryland
governor O'Connor ladies and gentlemen
nowhere in the world except in the
Americas is it possible for any nation
to devote a great sector of its effort
to light conservation rather than light
destruction all of us are grateful that
we in the United States can still turn
our thoughts and our attention to those
institutions of our country that
symbolized peace institutions whose
purpose it is to save life and not to
destroy it it is for the dedication of
these noble buildings to the service of
man that we are assembled here today the
National Institute of Health speaks the
universal language of humanitarianism it
has been devoted throughout its long and
distinguished history to furthering the
health of all mankind in which service
it has recognized no limitations imposed
by international boundaries and has
recognized no distinctions of race or
creed or color the total defense that we
have heard so much about of late that
total offense which this nation seeks
involves a great deal more than building
airplanes and ships and guns bombs but
we cannot be a strong nation unless we
are a healthy nation and so we must
recruit not only men and materials but
also knowledge and science in the
service of national strength and that is
what we are doing here we have
recognized the strategic importance of
hell
by the creation of a Health and Medical
Center committee in the Council of
National Defense itself that committee
has the job of coordinating the health
and medical aspects of National
Preparedness that committee is assisting
the government in the mobilization of
the medical and health resources of the
country to serve the best interests both
of the military and the civilian
elements of the nation to do this will
require the best energies of
professional and technical leadership
everywhere in the United States to do
this will require the fullest
cooperation between the government and
the hospitals the medical the dental
nursing and other professions we seek
the same partnership that we seek for
industrial production in the Advisory
Committee neither the American people
nor that government intend to socialize
medical practice any more than they plan
to socialize industry in American life
the family duska the general
practitioner performs a service which we
rely upon and which we as a nation and
there can be no substitute for the
personal relationship between doctor and
team which is a characteristic and a
source of strength of medical practice
in our land although we have a gradiated
going the nation today I am very certain
is better prepared to meet the public
health
grams of our emergency then at any
previous time in the history of the
country since the passage of the famous
Social Security Act with its health
provisions in 1935 federal and state and
local health and medicine are
cooperating more broadly than ever
before our people are better informed on
health matters than ever before
scientific knowledge of the causes of
disease and also the conditions for
health has exceeded any previous limits
facilities where health and medical
service are more numerous and that
better the Public Health Service of the
United States is a very old institution
and has done magnificent work but it is
only recently in the past few years that
the federal government has indicated
that it can do infinitely more the
disease disregards state lines as well
as national lines but among the states
there is as we know and in equality of
opportunity for health in such cases the
Public Health Service is healthy and
must continue even more greatly to help
that partnership and I emphasize that
word regardless health medicine
throughout the land that partnership is
making definite progress among many
diseases among the buildings of the
National Institute of Health to be
dedicated here today stands the National
Cancer Institute created through
visions of the ACT which i signed on
August 5th 1937 the work of this new
Institute is well underway it is
promoting and stimulating cancer
research throughout the nation it is
bringing to the people of the nation a
message of hope because many forms of
the disease are not only curable but
even preventable beyond this it is doing
research here and in many universities
to unravel the mysteries of cancer I
think we can all have faith in the
ultimate results of these great efforts
these buildings that we dedicate
represent new and improved housing for
an institution that is we want a long
and distinguished background of
accomplishment in this task of research
the original demonstration of the cause
and method of preventing peligro for
example has been followed by other
important contributions great work has
been done in the control of tularemia
Rocky Mountain spotted fever typhus
fever yellow fever malaria and
psittacosis now that we are less than a
day by plane from the jungle type the
yellow fever of South America less than
two days from the sleeping sickness of
Equatorial Africa less than three days
think cholera and bubonic plague the
ramparts we watch must be civilian in
addition to being military
for the very beautiful and very spacious
grounds on which these buildings stand
we are indebted to mr. and mrs. Luke
Wilson
who wrote to me in 1935 asking a bit
part of their estate at Bethesda in
Maryland could be yours to the benefit
of the people of this nation I would
tell her now that ash as she sits beside
me that in the capacity of the
compassion of mr. and mrs. Wilson for
suffering in their hope for human action
to alleviate it she and her husband
symbolized the aspirations of millions
of Americans for a cause such as this
and we are very grateful
today's the need for the conservation of
health and physical fitness is greater
than at any time in the nation's history
dedicating this Institute I dedicated to
the underlying philosophy of public
health to the conservation of life to
the wise use of the vital resources of
the nation i voice for America and for
the stricken world our hopes our prayers
faith in the power of man's humanity
demand
the President of the United States has
dedicated the National Institute of
Health a collection of six buildings
Sutton the sloping hills of the Thousand
Island of Technology
the president spoke in this pleasant
royal setting in Bethesda Maryland near
Washington DC this afternoon after a
quick automobile drives from Washington
DC the capital city in which she arrived
a few minutes after 10 o'clock this
morning and now the small audience which
has come out to watch the president
dedicate this National Institute of
Health is now moving away and the
president will soon motor back to the
White House in Washington this is bad
crowd speaking this is the Columbia
Broadcasting System